you've probably seen this ad many many
many times right you don't need keto you
don't need paleo you don't need intense
exercise you don't even need to fast or
even do a vegan diet and you can burn
fat and get shredded so please comment
down below if you've seen this ad before
the best way to burn fat and get
shredded is not keto not paleo
like this I mean people must be buying
this program because they're advertising
a lot and they wouldn't spend all this
money in advertising if they weren't
selling this program and it's your
typical let's shock people into clicking
this ad so you can maybe just possibly
not have to do anything and lose your
weight you can also eat pizza instead of
salad which one do you think I'm having
for dinner tonight well it's not this as
long as you align your actions with the
body type so what does v-shred recommend
to eat well here's an example for
breakfast you can have oatmeal and fruit
you can have a mid-morning snack with an
apple and nuts for lunch you can have a
salad with chicken and then an afternoon
snack carrots and hummus and then for
dinner teriyaki chicken with vegetables
and some berries you can even have
popcorn and you can have bread on this
diet as long as you eliminate the added
sugars and processed foods so let me
just do a little bit of a deep dive not
a very long deep dive but in to
something that's very very important
just so you don't end up doing a program
and wasting your money and then chalking
it up to another thing that just didn't
work in the hopes that maybe this is the
answer that I can finally lose weight
maybe I'm eating too healthy or reducing
too many carbs or maybe I'm exercising
too much right 80 percent of your
results are going to be diet
and twenty percent are related to
exercise what does that actually mean
and is it actually true and I'm going to
tell you that it's not actually true it
really depends on another thing okay
because there's two things about diet
it's of course what you eat if you know
anything about fat burning it's really
tied into the insulin component part
right if you lower your insulin and your
body can now stop storing fat and you
can start burning your fat and that's
basically really about lowering your
carbohydrates the lower that you bring
your carbohydrates the more fat you're
going to burn well it doesn't always
work so there's this other variable of
when you eat okay because there are a
lot of people who I know who go on the
ketogenic diet low carb diet and they're
healthy foods
they don't lose any weight of course
when you look at the frequency of eating
they're eating three meals with three
snacks but that's all good food so why
can some people lose weight and yet
other people can't
it has to do with this one thing and
that is insulin resistance if they have
insulin resistance which by the way is
about 70 percent of the population the
people that are successful just by
reducing carbohydrates just like the
simple sugars and some of the refined
foods that is a much smaller percent of
the population but they can actually
lose weight because they don't have
insulin resistance somehow they never
got it maybe it's part genetics maybe
they haven't lived on so many carbs and
sugar like the rest of us but the point
is the more insulin resistance you have
the more you have to not just lower your
carbs but the more you have to do
infrequent eating that's called
intermittent fasting now if we just take
a look at the two main things that
increase insulin
carbohydrates and the frequency of
eating as in a lot of different meals a
lot of different snacks if we just take
a look at those two things and we
compare them I'm going to tell you right
now
the frequency of eating and the snacks
is way way way way more important and
way more significant than just lowering
your carbs because there are a lot of
people that can pretty much eat whatever
they want and they're still able to lose
weight but they only eat just one meal a
day with absolutely no snacking versus a
much smaller percent of the population
would start reducing their carbs
and they haven't introduced intermittent
fasting yet but some of those people
will lose weight okay but not a large
percentage and when we're talking about
this uh bee shred guy he's pretty much
focusing on a very small percent of the
population that can lose weight just by
reducing some of the junk foods and
reducing the added sugars and the
processed sugar because he allows fruit
and things like that I mean the reason I
know this is because my initial diet was
very similar to his I didn't recommend
intermittent fasting I did recommend
these snacks apples and nuts lowered fat
and a very similar diet and I was
successful to some degree I wouldn't say
that it was a high level of success like
it is now so if you wanted to know can
you lose weight
and eat what you want yes you can versus
a certain small percent of the
population who does not have insulin
resistance they just need to cut down a
little bit on their carbs but for
everyone else that has insulin
resistance which is like 70 of the
population uh they're gonna have to do
fasting like one meal a day and they
will definitely experience results but
my whole point is why not combine
intermittent fasting with the reduction
of carbohydrates because it's not just
about weight loss it's about reducing
your inflammation it's about removing
fat from the liver it's about looking
good as you lose weight because your
skin is better and you're not putting
all these other things in your body that
don't contribute to healthy cells it's
also about reducing your risk for all
the other chronic degenerative type
problems however in this video I really
just wanted to differentiate the
different variables in losing weight so
you can kind of wrap your wits around it
and understand why some people lose
weight on a certain diet and others will
not and what they have to do and for a
lot of people especially with insulin
resistance it's not just lowering your
carbohydrates it will help it will
actually get rid of like two weeks of
water weight but unless you add that
intermittent fasting which is way way
way more significant than just lowering
your carbs you probably are not going to
see a big change so my suggestion is
also not to just lower your carbs it's
to increase the quality of your food
that's called healthy keto and implement
the intermittent fasting as well as the
right exercise and also as a side note
the reason why some top athletes can get
away with eating a lot of sugar is
because the exercise stimulates the
mitochondria in kind of neutralizes to
some degree some of this
this sugar effect on your mitochondria
which I don't recommend it but just so
you know exercise I think is really
important not just for weight loss but
for
stimulating your mitochondria which is
at the heart of so many health problems
out there now if you really wanted to
know how to do healthy keto just the
basics you should watch this video right
here